this year Russians built an app that
rewires our social fabric for all of
human history when you stepped into a
park like this strolling around enjoying
a brisk fall day you've been in public
but unknown lost in the stream of
friendly faces until now would you mind
if I take a photo of your face we've
tried to do a little bit of an
experiment can I take a photo of your
face I just take a photo of you and then
let's see we see if I can find your vk4
Fang you might find me on Facebook it
doesn't work on Facebook yet because
they don't let you search the database
fine face is an Android app that lets
you take a picture of a new friend or a
complete stranger in a few seconds it
scans all 250 million photos from VK the
Russian Facebook back off and then finds
a match all right let's see what happens
moment of truth here we go oh oh it's me
it's absolutely oh it's me yes is me and
your hairs so different in the gutter
definitely find me first
yeah so it works yeah it's really cool
do you think it's strange it's strange
but cool you like some girl and she'll
take a full day and you can find her and
takes care subject yeah you you guys
like it I wouldn't like this so if I
forgot if this my son or not
I can be check it out with my father
okay this year fine face took its
algorithm to America for something
called the mega face challenge there
it'd be Google and a lot of other face
squatting software
to find out how they did it nice nice to
meet you I went to meet the algorithms
creator at the office of his company and
tech do you mind showing me how the
technology works a little bit here can
we try me so these are my Russian
brethren my cousin's is it right in
order by who they think looks the most
like this is like a 60 year old with a
machine gun another guy with a gun I
want to show you something else why am i
a bad soldier similarity is very long
but you're so good at things that there
some some similarity sometimes it's
difficult to say why narrow Network
works this way but but it works Artem
programmed the neural network that
approaches face fighting differently
than others he fed it thousands of image
matches and after about six months of
training
voila it learned to read faces
essentially you don't even know what the
neural network is seeing in the
beginning narrow Network gives random
answers and the accuracy is close to
zero and during training if everything
goes well the acoustic rows and cells
called neurons some combinations of
these names responsible for race some
combinations responsible for type of
eyes if you can efficiently find the
exact person among huge datasets it
opens a lot more interesting use cases
like for example you can search for
criminals in real life among all the
street car know since ICT are we creeped
out yet maybe we should be
ntek has already signed a contract with
the Moscow City police though Artyom
won't talk about it and he says they
already have agreements with other law
enforcement agencies both inside and
outside Russia it's easy to imagine what
the FBI or its Russian counterpart the
FSB could do with this kind of
technology so it's a little bit
controversial right because anyone can
identify you now the crowd I would say
that the implications of this very scary
I think F is bears watching us like them
I'm saying like companies here are big
companies corporations and governments
doesn't know everything about you but
referendum people this makes a small
much easier you have to be careful if
you go in outside in the street or in
the Facebook or any other social network
you'll be on it yeah you open to be
recognized this idea that you're not
anonymous when you walk the street
anymore somebody can just snap your
photo and identify who you are you must
have thought about that when you were
developing the technology when we were
developing we were thinking wrongly
about equity and how called Fortis but
why was she finished and to have
smartphones with your because they can
flag all the information about you it's
a battle between technology and privacy
my personal Gaza technology will win
[Music]